こんにちは
今僕は皆さん
ありましたけれども今日これからお話しするアイデアは自分の個人的なこれまでの行き
方についての一つのアイディアについてお話をしたいと思います
あえてあなたという言葉を意識した内容にしていきたいとおもいます
今日のお話を聞いていただいて
今後
あなたと私の
今日はアイディア共有の場という風に考えていただければ幸いです
今日お話しすることは
これです
これだけでもちょっとわからないと思いますけれども
行動これが10です
ご自身あなたの点が行動です
それを線で結んでそれを未来に向かって広げていく
これが
あなたとあなたのさらに周りの人
お友達家族に対して良い影響を与えて結果的にはより良い社会づくりにつながると
いったことをお話をしていきたいと思っています
当然ですが点と線の
取り方つなぎ方というのは人それぞれ違っています
私が経験 ab というもの
経験しているとすればあなたは経験 xk 県 y
いうものを経験していますそれぞれな
経験の点と線の繋ぎかたそれをどう未来につなげていくかというものは違っています
当然これは違って当たり前です
ただ人間というものは社交性がありますのでこの点がかみ合う
接する点というものがいます接点というものがあります
それは出会いとタイミングになります
超のテレックス陸橋いうまさにこれも私とあなたとの
貴重な出会いのタイミングです
一つの経験
を
私とあなたで共有する一つのタイミングになっています
ちょっとこれアンケートを取りたいんですが
今日オーディエンスの方に納税をお越しいただいていますけれども
立教大学の大学生の方学部生大学院
どうどうぐらいいらっしゃるでしょうかあの挙手で構いませんので
立教大学以外の
学生の方学部生大学院生の方あっ
思います
僕と同じようにもうすでに社会人として働いていらっしゃるという形の
の様々な経験を持った方々が脅威だして
ただそうは言っても行動は何をしてもいいというものではありません
自分の行動には必ず責任というものが伴ってきます
なので夜中にルールというものがありますけれども自分の行動あなたの行動にも必ず
責任というものが止まってきます
僕意味社会人という立場ですけれども
社会人という言葉には社会に対して何らかのお返し
責任を果たす人という意味が含まれているとぼくは理解していますではその社会に
対する責任というものは何でしょうか
まとめてみました
今日本では社会的責任という言葉が洗えるところ
使われていますいくつかピックアップをしてみました
おそらく皆さんの中で一番なじみがあるよく聞く言葉は csr という言葉ではない
でしょうか
corporate social レスポンスびりてぃです
企業の社会的責任と言う
これは各企業が住所自分たちの csr 方針などを決めて活動をされています
最近では大学でも us あるという言葉が出てきました大学の社会的責任とは何か
ということを大学でも
今日注目したいのは
個人の社会的席
パーソナルソーシャルレスポンスビリティという考えです
パーソナルの責任というのは
自分が社会に対してどういった責任は果たせるのか
どういうお返しが出来るのかを自分で自由に決められるもの
というふうに僕は考えています
csr は usr は組織として
ちゃん決めて方針を決めていますが
の psr については自分で決めて自分で気づきを得て変えていく考えていくものだ
というふうに思っています
僕自身とっての ps あるというのは
自分がこれまで経験してきたことを伝えて
あなたやあなたのさらにその先の人々に良い影響を与えて
良い影響を与えていくそのスタート地点
最初の地点を担っていく責任があると思っています
なぜ自分がすぴー sr というのを意識したかと
これから大きな経験を2つお話しします
一つは僕は2005年から2007年まで
jica の青年海外協力隊という授業がありますこれでモザンビークの
アフリカの南東部にあるモザンビークという国に2年間派遣をされて
暮らしていました age 対策の退院です
jica の青年海外協力隊はボランティア事業でありますがこれは日本の国\がはを
行っている事業なので税金が使われます
常に働いている方々が納税していただいたお金を持って
自分は2年間海外に赴任をして活動をしてきました
なので自分がその税金をどういうふうに伝えて使ってきたか使ったかというものを
伝える責任があると自分は捉えています
自分が出たこととしてはまず税金ですね
直接的には税金が間接的直接的ではないですけど間接的には税金が
れてそこでまず日本で訓練を受けます語学で語学の訓練
覇権国の現地号学ぶ
あとは時間管理ですとか体力作りを含めた
規則正しい生活というものも現地君が現地前の訓練に付けますそして
専門知識です僕の場合は a ず予防という専門知識を
そして源氏の人々に何を返ししてきたかというと
専門的な技術知識というものはもちろんなんですけれども
モザンビークの人々多くは日本人という人知りませんので
日本人としての振る舞いや大道というものも自分がモデルとなる事で一つを開始ができ
たんじゃないかなと思っています
あともしかしたらこちらの会場の中にいらっしゃるかもしれませんしれませんが将来的
に青年海外協力隊じゃ何か何らかの形でボランティアに関わっていきたいという人に
次に
渡すバトンというものを残すことができたのではないかなというふうに思っています
一つ目は伝える責任です
もう一つの大きな経験は
この立教大学の大学院での社会人
大学院生としての生活でした
これは私責任というものを強く意識した2年間を過ごしています
21世紀社会デザイン研究科での経験です
社会人経験をある程度長く経験してから自分は大学院入学したわけですけれども
まさかあの
修士論文というものを書いて自分がまた学生に戻るというのを数年前までは全く夢にも
思っていませんでした
自分自身としては自分の仕事の専門性を高めたいという
思い出当初入学がしましたけれども結果的には世の中に修士論文というものを残して
終了をしました
修士論文を書くにはその自分が研究する分野の多くの人たちの先行研究これを調べて
つげん積み上げてそこに自分の考えを載せるということを行いますので多くの方々の
戦線神の知識を自分は得てきました
もう一つは
昼間働いて夜は学校に行くというこのまま二重生活ですね
時間管理剣豪面を含めた自己管理というものも能力としてかなり
自分でも身についたもの
結果的には社会に対しては修士論文という自分の作品を残すことができました
そして自分と同じに多様な分野を持った
次の研究者へのバトンを論文という形で使ってもらえるようにバトンを残せたのでは
ないかなというふうに思っていますすいませから振り返ると大きく伝え
責任と私的にこれを自分なりに
強く気づきを得たというものが大きかったと思いますこれが2つの大きな自分の点に
なります
psr 個人の社会的責任というのは誰から与えられるものではなく自分で気づいて
自分で意識していくものだと僕は思っていますなので今日来てくださったあなたも
あなたも
そしてあなたもこれからは psr というものをほんの少しだけ意識して生活やお
仕事などに役立てて行って頂けると嬉しいと思います
僕もまだまだ店を増やしている最中ですこれから
戦も伸ばしていきます
私もあなたも様々な点を増やして線を伸ばしていく
その中であるところも経験は今日のように設定となります
この接点をどんどん増やしていっていただきたいと思います
当然ですが人それぞれ考え方も違いますし
これまで経験してきたことも違うのでぶつかることもあると思います
意見が合わないということもありますただそれはそういうそれを恐れずにぜひ相手を
尊重するという気持ちを持って
今後のよりよい社会に向けた社会を作るということに向けてぜひ積極的に切片を作ると
いうことに取り組んでいただければと思います
僕自身も2年間モザンビークという言葉も違う
就業も違う生活文化も全く違うところに年間
生活をしてさまざまな人々と接点をつくってきました
立教大学の大学院では世代も違うそれぞれの仕事も違う人々と同じ授業を受けることで
自分自身も接点を増やしてきましたし大きな刺激を受けました
これは自分の今でも財産になっています
僕はその財産を自分だけのものにするのではなくて社会に広くお返しすることが重要だ
と思っています
なので是非
今日から頭の片隅にぜひあなたもみなさんも
を改修していくということを意識していただければ幸いです
これは自分なりのアイディアのまとめになりますヒトは社会を作るアーティストです
自分をアーティしたあなたもアーティストです作る作品は社会というものになる
点と線は行動と言えますそこに psr
個人ない自分の社会に果たす責任というものを意識してよりよい影響を周りに与えて
より多様な人々が共存できる社会というのを作っていく
でさらにその共存できる社会が次なる手にアセントなって循環していく
こうなっていくことであなたの生き方や社会というのもさらに面白くなっていくと思い
ますし今後の震度や社会のあり方というのもデザインしていく受けで
していく上でもっと面白いものになっていくと僕は信じています
ぜひこれからあなたの生き方も
私の生き方も
この社会作り方というのも面白く一緒にしていきたいと思っています
最後になりますけれども今日からあなたに一つできることを最後にお話ししたいと思い
ます
それぞれ
いろいろな経験をされてきたと思います主な
経験をどういったものがあるかいくつが頭の中で
点を
作って見て頂けますでしょうか
今
パッと浮かずもので結構です
その点と点を線でん
結んでみてください
そうしてその線を未来に伸ばした時に
あなた自身が周りの人々
自分の友だちや家族
職場の人たちにどういったお返しができるでしょうか
何かこれまでにない日付というものが得られればそれはあなたにとってあなたにしか
できない
あなたならではの財産ですし社会へのお返しの仕方だと思っています是非この気持ちや
考えというものを今日から少しずつ意識して今後のをより良い社会付く
より良い自分の意思形でいうものをデザインして言って頂ければ嬉しく思います
今日はありがとうございました
[拍手]